BETTER TRY HARDER NEXT TIME,
GUYS.
THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW ARE TWO PEOPLE
WHO WORKED ON THE INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL OF KEN STARR AND SAUL
WEISBERG.
JOINING ME IS KEVIN BRAGA TO
ASSISTANT FBI DIRECTOR FOR
INTELLIGENCE BY MUELLER AND
CAUCUS CHAIR MARK MEADOWS.
CAN COME KEN, WHAT WAS MUELLER
BIGGEST SCREWUP TODAY?
>> TOTAL LACK OF PREPARATION OR
AT LEAST THE INABILITY FOR
WHATEVER REASON TO COMMUNICATE,
TO SHOW A MASTERLY OR MASTERY O
BASIC KNOWLEDGE OF THE REPORT.
I WAS STUNNED AND THEN I WAS
SHOCKED BY BOB'S INABILITY TO
FOCUS, TO SHOW THAT HE
UNDERSTOOD THE QUESTIONS, THE
CONSTANT PLEAS WORKWEEK THE
QUESTION.
SOMETIMES YOU DO THAT AS A
WITNESS TO STALL AND GATHER YOU
THOUGHTS, BUT IT SEEMED TO BE
GENUINE.
WHAT WAS THAT QUESTION?
HE WAS IN A STATE OF
BEFUDDLEMENT WHICH BECAME MY
THINKING EMBARRASSING.
I WOULD SAY EARLY ON I WAS SO
GLAD TO SEE THAT THE ISSUE OF
EXONERATION AND THE IDEA OF A
PROSECUTOR TAKING IT ON HIMSELF
FOR NOW WE KNOW THE TEAM TAKING
IT ON THEM SEEMS, TAKING IT ON
THEMSELVES TO SAY THIS REPORT
DOES NOT EXONERATE THE PRESIDENT
.
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS NOW.
TOTALLY INAPPROPRIATE, TOTALLY
IMPROPER, AND NOW WE KNOW THAT
IT'S MUCH MORE LIKELY SOMETHING
THAT BOB MUELLER DID NOT IN HIS
JUDGMENT COME TO.
IT WAS THE JUDGMENT OF THE
MUELLER TEAM.
>>LAURA: MARK MEADOWS, I'M
GOING TO GO DEAL.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO THIS
BECAUSE HE WAS ASKED ABOUT WHO
APPOINTED HIM AT THIS HEARING.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO MISSED THIS
, WATCH.
>> WHICH PRESIDENT APPOINTED YO
TO BECOME THE UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY FOR MASSACHUSETTS?
>> WHICH SENATOR?
>> WHICH PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK THAT WAS PRESIDENT
BUSH.
>> ACCORDING TO MY NOTES IT WAS
PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN.
>>LAURA: THE PRESIDENT HAS BEE
THROUGH, HIS FAMILY HAS BEEN
THROUGH.
THEY HAVE HAD TO GO THROUGH ALL
THIS TESTIMONY THEY WERE
VILIFIED, AND EVERYBODY BUILD
HIM UP TO BE THIS GUY, WE CUT M
SOUNDBITE NOW,  BUT HE WALKED O
WATER.
I DIDN'T BUY IT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
ANY TIMES THE ELITE OLD SOMEONE
UP TO THIS DEMIGOD STATUS COME
OUT MY ANTENNA ALWAYS GOES UP.
THIS WAS A SHAME FROM THE
BEGINNING.
HE WAS NOT WITH IT.
AND HE IS RUNNING THIS
INVESTIGATION THAT COULD AFFECT
U.S. POLITICS?
>> I WAS THERE NEXT TO BOB
MUELLER FOR THE ENTIRE JUDICIAR
MEETING AND IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT
HE WAS NOT PRAYER IT.
AND HE DIDN'T HAVE A GRASP OF.
>>LAURA: THE BASIC FACTS OF
THIS INVESTIGATION.
THE WHOLE PANEL KNOWS MORE ABOU
THIS INVESTIGATION THEN BOB
MUELLER DOES.
>> THAT WAS MEANT TO BE A
SOFTBALL QUESTION BY A DEMOCRAT
AND IT WAS A SWING AND A MISS.
IT WAS JUST A SAD DAY.
>>LAURA: YOU WORKED WITH HIM,
YOU KNOW HIM, I ASSUME YOU THIN
HE IS A MAN OF GREAT INTEGRITY.
YOUR VIEW?
>> I DO.
I GOT A LOT OF TEXT MESSAGES AN
TWEETS FROM COLLEAGUES AND THE
OPERATIVE WORD TODAY SEEMS TO B
PAINFUL.
IT'S NOT THE BOB MUELLER THAT W
REMEMBER.
WE LOSE A LITTLE BIT OF VERBAL
DEXTERITY OVER THE YEARS, BUT I
THINK HIS BASIC UNFAMILIARITY
WITH THE REPORT ITSELF, HAVING
TO PULL IN HIS DEPUTY FOR BACKU
COMMIT DOES NOT INSPIRE
CONFIDENCE AND HIS ANSWERS TODA
DID NOT INSPIRE CONFIDENCE THAT
HE WAS A MAN IN CONTROL.
>> THE DEPUTY SEEMED LIKE
CARETAKERS.
THIS IS THE U.S. PRESIDENCY
INVOLVED.
WE WERE LED TO BELIEVE THAT THI
WAS GOING TO BE THE BEST OF THE
BEST, THE FAIREST OF THE FAIREST
, AND IT WASN'T.
SAUL, YOU HAVE BEEN A BIG
DEFENDER OF MUELLER FROM THE
BEGINNING.
YOU NEVER WORKED WITH HIM,  BUT
AFTER TODAY, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> I'VE BEEN A BIG DEFENDER OF
HIS INTEGRITY FROM THE BEGINNIN
AND I'M STILL A DEFENDER OF HIS
INTEGRITY.
I'M NOT GOING TO KICK HIM WHEN
HE'S DOWN.
LIKE KEVIN, I GOT TEXT MESSAGES
FROM PEOPLE OUT OF THE BLUE,
PEOPLE I HAVEN'T TALKED TO, NEX
FBI IN YEARS THAT SAID LITERALL
THIS IS NOT THE BOB MUELLER THA
I KNEW.
SOMETHING IS WRONG.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN THAT STARTED,
BUT I KNOW TO ME THAT FAILURE
TODAY IS A FAILURE OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS MAN SAID THE REPORT SPEAKS
FOR ITSELF.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY ANYTHING
BEYOND WHAT'S ON IN THE REPORTS.
I THINK HE COULD HAVE BEEN MUCH
SHARPER THAN HE WAS TODAY HE
STILL WOULD NOT HAVE GIVEN THEM
WHAT THEY WANT TO HEAR.
WHEN YOU DO NOT GIVE THEM WHAT
THEY WANT TO HEAR, THEY DESTROY
YOU AS THEY'VE BEEN DOING ALL
DAY AND THEY ARE DOING TONIGHT
BECAUSE THE RUTHLESS.
>>LAURA: I HAVE A PIECE OF
ADVICE I END OFFERED ON TWITTER
TODAY I HELD MY FIRE UNTIL THE
END OF THE TESTIMONY,  BUT MINE
WAS COMMITTEE, WHEN YOU WANT A
BIG HEARING, AND A LAWYER THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO CALL REALLY
DOESN'T WANT TO TESTIFY, YOU
THINK IS GOING TO MAKE YOUR
POINT, DON'T BRING HIM TO
TESTIFY.
HE SAID HE DIDN'T WANT TO
I THINK MAYBE HE KNEW HE DIDN'T
KNOW THE UNDERLYING FACTS.
WE ARE GOING TO GET TO SOME OF
THESE FACTS LIKE THIS DEAL
DOSSIER IN A MOMENT.
HE SAID HE DIDN'T WANT TO
TESTIFY AND BARR SAID IN THAT
LETTER, STICK TO THE REPORT.
HE WANDERED OFF A FEW TIMES WHE
HE WANTED TO END THE DEMOCRATS
ASKED HIM SOME QUESTIONS.
THE REPUBLICANS WE'RE SHUT DOWN
NOT GOING TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION,  BUT HE NEVER WANTED
TO DO THIS TESTIMONY.
>> FROM WHAT WE KNOW, THIS WAS
JUST AN ENORMOUS MISJUDGMENT
BECAUSE NOW THAT WE LOOK BACK I
HINDSIGHT, WE NOW SEE SOME OF
THE WARNING SIGNS.
HIS PRESS CONFERENCE WHERE HE
SAID NO QUESTIONS.
I THINK IT'S FUNDAMENTAL TO
DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY THAT PEOPLE
WHO HOLD POWER AS HE DID AT THA
TIME, HAVE TO BE RESPONSIVE NOT
JUST OF THE CONGRESS OF THE
UNITED STATES, BUT TO THE MEDIA.
PROSECUTORS HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
ABOUT WHAT THEY SAY, BUT HE HAD
ISSUED HIS REPORT SO IT WAS TIM
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS INCLUDING
THE QUESTIONS BEING RAISED ABOU
THE INTEGRITY NOT ABOUT MUELLER
BUT ABOUT HIS TEAM AND
ESPECIALLY THE POLITICAL
LEANINGS.
ALL OF THAT HAD BEEN IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN,  BUT HE HAD NEVE
RESPONDED TO THESE I THINK VERY
REASONABLE AND IN FACT POWERFUL
QUESTIONS.
HE SAID I'M NOT GOING TO RESPON
SO I THINK THAT WAS A.
>>LAURA: CONGRESSMAN, I WANT T
PLAY THE EXCHANGE ABOUT THE
STEEL DOSSIER PAIR THIS IS WHAT
THEY GOT THE INVESTIGATION GOING
.
FOR EVERYBODY WHO LIVED UNDER A
ROCK THAT WAS THIS DOSSIER
COMPILED LISTS OPPOSING SOURCES
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT ALL A BUNCH
OF PHONY BALONEY STUFF PAID FOR
ULTIMATELY BY THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
THIS WAS THE EXCHANGE ABOUT THI
DEAL DOSSIER.
>> WHEN DID YOU BECOME AWARE
THAT THE UNVERIFIED STEEL
DOSSIER WAS INTENDED WAS
INCLUDED IN THE APPLICATION TO
SPY ON CARTER PAGE?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO SPEAK TO
THAT.
>> YOUR TEAM INTERVIEWED BECAUS
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, CORRECT?
>> YOU CAN'T TELL THIS COMMITTE
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT YOU
INTERVIEWED CHRISTOPHER STEELE
IN AN INVESTIGATION WITH 18
LAWYERS?
>> THAT IS ONE OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT IS BEING
HANDLED BY OTHERS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> IT WAS REALLY THAT MOMENT AN
ONE MOMENT BEFORE WHEN HE SAID
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT FUSION GPS
IS ALL ABOUT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT BOTH OF THOSE,
YOU'VE BEEN COVERING THIS.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT JUST YOU
THAT'S BEEN COVERING IT, IT'S
BEEN ALL OVER FOR TWO YEARS.
ADAM SCHIFF HAS TALKED ABOUT IT
DEVIN NUNES HAS TALKED ABOUT IT
AND HERE WE ARE WITH BOB MUELLE
NOT BEING ABLE TO ANSWER BASIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION.
YOU HIT AN EARLIER .
HERE.
THE DEMOCRATS FORCED BOB MUELLE
TO DO THIS.
IT WAS FIRST THEY WANTED TO WAI
FOR THE MUELLER REPORT, THEN
THEY WANTED HIM TO COME BACK AN
THEY WANTED HIM TO DO A PRESS
CONFERENCE AND THEN THEY WANTED
HIM TO SHOW UP.
THREE TIMES THEY HAVE STRUCK OUT
.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET THEY NEED
TO STOP WHILE THEY'RE BEHIND.
RIGHT NOW THEY ARE SO BEHIND,
THEY NEED TO JUST STOP,.
>>LAURA: THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS WHAT ANDREA MITCHELL
SAID ABOUT THE LINE OF INQUIRY
ABOUT THE STEEL DOSSIER.
>> IT IS SHAMEFUL.
SHAMEFUL THAT REPUBLICANS ARE S
FOCUSED ON TRYING TO UNDERMINE
THE ORIGINS OF THE INVESTIGATIO
THAT THEY DID NOT DEAL WITH THE
FACTS THAT HAS BEEN CONCLUDED B
ALL OF THE INTELLIGENCE AGENCIE
UNDER OBAMA AND OF COURSE
PROFESSIONALS.
>> THIS IS THE GAPING HOLE IN
THE WHOLE INVESTIGATION.
BOB MUELLER WAS HANDED A MANDAT
TO DO A COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION HE RAN OFF AND DI
A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
IGNORING A LOT OF THE BASIC
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE QUESTIONS
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN ASKED IN
ONE OF THEM SURROUNDS THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF THE DOSSIER IN THE
RUSSIAN INVOLVEMENT IN THAT IN
THEIR EFFORTS TO THAT MANIPULAT
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
>> WE LEARN TODAY JUST HOW MUCH
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION WAS
IMPACTED BY THIS SO-CALLED
OBSTRUCTION THAT THEY CLAIMED
THAT NEVER ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
SPOILER ALERT, IT WASN'T
EFFECTIVE AT ALL.
>> WE NEVER FIRED AS SPECIAL
COUNSEL, MR. MUELLER.
WERE YOU ALLOWED TO COMPLETE
YOUR INVESTIGATION UNENCUMBERED?
>> ES.
>> IN FACT, HE RESIGNED AS
SPECIAL COUNSEL WHEN YOU CLOSED
UP THE OFFICE IN LATE MAY OF
2019, IS THAT CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
TO GIVE THE CONGRESSWOMAN DID
THIS IN LIKE THREE QUESTIONS.
WAS IT IMPEDED, WASN'T FIRED,
FINISH THE INVESTIGATION.
SOMETIME I'M CRITICAL OF THE
REPUBLICANS CROSS-EXAMINATION
TECHNIQUE I THINK THEY BRING IN
REAL PROS LIKE YOU TO DO THE
INVESTIGATION,  BUT SHE WAS
FANTASTIC.
>> SHE WAS GREAT BUT EVERYBODY
SHOULD HAVE TAKEN A CRACK.
IN SKILLED CROSS EXAMINER HAVIN
BEEN WHEN YOURSELF WOULD ROLL I
OUT AND ASKED 20 QUESTIONS.
YOU WERE ALLOWED TO TALK TO THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS.
YOU WERE ALLOWED TO SEE
EXTENSIVE NOTES INVOLVING
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN DON Mc
GANN AND THE PRESIDENT.
YOU WERE ALLOWED TO QUESTION
ANYBODY WANTED TO OVER EXNER
NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
DID ANYONE EVER CLAIM EXECUTIVE
PLEURA VILLAGE.
YOU COULD HAVE IS 50 OR 60
QUESTIONS LIKE THAT.
THE ANSWER WOULD HAVE BROUGHT
OUT NOBODY EVER KEPT US FROM
QUESTIONING ANYBODY EXCEPT FOR
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF WHICH
EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT THAT ISSUE
.
I WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE SEEN
THAT.
>>LAURA: EXCELLENT POINT.
THERE WAS ANOTHER .
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT BEFORE
THEIR SHOW WHICH IS WE HAD ALL
THESE DEMOCRAT PLAYERS WHO ANY
OF OUR LAW PRACTICES WHEN WE
TAKE A CASE YOU DO A CONFLICT
CHECK.
IT'S A PAIN IN THE NECK, DID YO
EVER MEET THIS PERSON, DO YOU
KNOW ANYONE.
THE CONFLICT CHECKS ARE
LABORIOUS IN ALLOWED FORM.
THIS IS A MINI LAW FORM, REALLY
IMPORTANT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
OFFICE.
YOU DON'T WANT ANY APPEARANCE O
CONFLICT LET ALONE ACTUAL
CONFLICTS.
THIS IS A LINE OF QUESTIONING
ABOUT JEANNIE REED ET CETERA.
>> ATTENDED THE HILLARY
CLINTON'S ELECTION NIGHT PARTY.
WERE YOU AWARE THAT MS. JEANNIE
REED REPRESENTED HILLARY CLINTO
IN LITIGATION REGARDING PERSONA
E-MAILS ORIGINATING AS HER TIME
AS SECRETARY OF STATE.
>> HAS S.
>> WHEN DID YOU FIRST LEARN
ABOUT THE ANIMUS TOWARDS DONALD
TRUMP.
>> IN THE SUMMER OF 2017.
>> YOU DIDN'T KNOW BEFORE HE WA
HIRED?
>> I DID NOT KNOW BEFORE THAT.
>> I WOULD LIKE THE WHOLE PANEL
TO WEIGH IN ON THIS.
WHAT YOU DO FOR A BASIC CONFLIC
OR APPEARANCE OF CONFLICT OF
CHECKS AND FOR AN OPERATION AS
IMPORTANT TO THE U.S. GOVERNMEN
CONSTITUTION.
FRANKLY THE WORLD IS THIS TEAM
WAS?
>> YOU DO YOUR DUE DILIGENCE.
YOU.
YOU ASK THE KEY QUESTIONS.
SO IS THERE ANYTHING AS WHEN
YOU'RE BEING CONSIDERED FOR AN
EXECUTIVE BRANCH APPROACHED
APPOINTMENT OR CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS, IS THERE ANYTHING THA
COULD BE EMBARRASSING TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
I THINK BOB OR WHOEVER WAS DOIN
IT, SHOULD HAVE SAID I NEED TO
KNOW.
I'M NOT ASKING YOU ANYTHING
ABOUT YOUR POLITICS.
BUT I NEED TO KNOW, IS THERE
ANYTHING BY THAT DEFINITION OF
POLITICALLY CHARGED
INVESTIGATION, ABOUT YOUR
BACKGROUND, WHAT YOU'VE DONE
THAT COULD PROVE EMBARRASSING T
THE INVESTIGATION IN TERMS OF
THE APPEARANCE OF IMPARTIALITY?
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT.
MY WORD, GIVEN THE GROUP OF
PEOPLE HE HAD AROUND HIM.
OF COURSE HE MUST MUST'VE KNOWN
ABOUT ANDREW WISEMAN'S
REPUTATION PROFESSIONALLY WHICH
HE CONTINUES TO STAND FIRM ON.
HE SHOULD HAVE ASKED THOSE TOUG
QUESTIONS.
>>LAURA: MARK MEADOWS, THIS IS
BIG.
DID ANYBODY DO A CONFLICT CHECK?
WHO DID THE CONFLICT CHECK OR
THE APPEARANCE OR ANYTHING.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES DID.
HE'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FO
TWO YEARS ABOUT THE CONFLICT.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS, JUST THE
BASIC ITEMS AND CREDIBILITY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT BOB
MUELLER SAID TODAY.
YOU SAY GOSH, YOU WANT TO HAVE
FAIR AND IMPARTIAL GROUP OF
PROSECUTORS.
>> THAT'S WHY BUILDING HIM UP
FROM THE BEGINNING IS THE
DEMIGOD, NO ONE WOULD QUESTION
HIM BECAUSE THIS IS BOB MUELLER
PAID YOU CAN'T QUESTION HIM.
HE WASN'T QUESTIONING WISEMAN O
WHOEVER WAS DOING IT.
HE DELEGATED IT.
WAS HE MORE OF A FIGUREHEAD IN
THIS INVESTIGATION?
AFTER YOU SAW THIS PERFORMANCE
TODAY WAS HE THE FIGUREHEAD?
HE CAME INTO THE OFFICE EVERY
DAY, HE MIGHT HAVE DONE
SOMETHING, BUT HE DID NOT KNOW
ANYTHING.
>> WHETHER HE WAS OR HE WASN'T,
THAT'S WHAT HE PROJECTED TODAY.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE HE'S A
MUCH MORE CAPABLE PERSON THAN
THAT.
THIS IS THE ACHILLES' HEEL OF
THE INVESTIGATION.
THE PERCEPTION WAS FRONTLOADED
WITH DEMOCRATS.
HE WASN'T ABLE TO GET AROUND
THAT.
>> TODAY ON THE PODCAST YOU WHE
I TALKED ABOUT THIS,  BUT THE
POLITICAL MORNING CONSOLE SHOWS
THAT EVEN MORE DEMOCRATS NOW
FROM APRIL THROUGH TODAY ARE
SAYING THAT THIS INVESTIGATION
WAS NOT HANDLED FAIRLY.
THAT PERCENTAGE HAS GONE UP 15
PERCENTAGE POINTS.
EVEN AMONG DEMOCRATS, THE
DISTRUST IS GROWING.
THIS IS NOT GOING IN A GOOD
DIRECTION FOR THE DEMOCRATS
GIVEN THE TIME, EFFORT, AND
PROMISES.
MOST PEOPLE ARE SAYING LET'S GE
GOING, LET'S WRAP THIS UP AT.
>> I THINK MOST AMERICANS HAVE
SENSE OF WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
NUMBER ONE THE CONCLUSIONS
CONSPIRACIES LET COORDINATION
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT,
THE PRESIDENT IS TOTALLY
EXONERATED AND THAT.
THE OBSTRUCTION FRONT HE
OVERREACTED HE DID SOME THINGS
THAT WE'RE NOT LIES THAT WE'RE
DISTURBING, THAT HE SHOULDN'T
HAVE DONE, BUT THERE IS PROBABL
NOT AN OBSTRUCTION CASE HERE AN
IF THERE WAS, HE IS THE
PRESIDENT AND WE CAN'T END ITEM
SO LET'S MOVE ON.
I THINK IN SOME KIND OF SINCE
MOST AMERICANS THINK THAT WAY.
YOU NOT GOING TO MOVE THE BALL
ANY FURTHER.
A PAGE OF HISTORY IS WORTH A
VOLUME OF LOGIC.
THE FACT IS THAT THIS ISN'T
WATERGATE, BUT NUMBER TO THE
REPUBLICANS CONTROL THE HOUSE
AND THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF TRUMP
'S PRESIDENCY AND THAT
MEANS THE DEMOCRATS WERE NOT
ABLE TO START ISSUING SUBPOENAS
INTO START BUILDING UP THE TYPE
OF INVESTIGATION THAT HAPPENED
IN WATERGATE.
THAT'S JUST REALITY, THAT'S JUS
POLITICS.
>>LAURA: NANCY BLOWS HE REACTE
TODAY INTO THIS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I DO BELIEVE THAT WHAT WE SA
TODAY WAS A VERY STRONG STRAW
MANIFESTATION SOME WOULD EVEN
SAY INDICTMENT OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S CONE OF SILENC
AND THEIR COVER-UP.
THIS IS ABOUT OUR TO PROTECT AN
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION.
>>LAURA: SHE'S USING THE WORD
INDICTMENT.
THEY ARE NOT LETTING THIS GO.
THE LANGUAGE IS 42020.
THIS IS ALL SETTING THE TABLE
FOR 2020.
>> IT ALWAYS WAS.
AT 2020 HEARING IT HAD NO BASIS
IN TRYING TO GET TO THE
UNDERLYING CRIME WHICH I BELIEV